President Trump is not now a criminal
target in the Russia investigation but
that could change and the president is
not out of the legal woods yet chief
intelligence correspondent Catherine
Herridge has our update tonight in early
March Special Counsel Robert Muller met
with the president's legal team and
confirmed he is not a criminal target
according to a source with knowledge of
the meeting the White House press
secretary would not talk specifics but
added nothing has changed we know what
we did and what we didn't do so none of
this comes as much of a surprise Fox
News has learned the March conversation
with Muller was over a possible
in-person interview a meeting defense
attorney said a person can start as a
witness the lowest-level then become a
subject and ultimately become the
criminal target for now the president is
considered a subject or witness in the
Russia probe when a prosecutor tells you
that your client is a witness a subject
or a target that could all change if the
prosecutor learns additional information
John Dowd Trump's lead attorney was
opposed to Trump appearing in front of
the special counsel dad resigned from
the case afterwards the president was
pressed on his position would you feel
like to testify the special counsel
Robert Miller sir after providing more
than three dozen witnesses and over a
million records on a voluntary basis the
source emphasized there's still no
evidence the president committed a crime
adding the media leak that Trump is not
currently a target appeared strategic on
skype Harvard Law Professor Alan
Dershowitz they're telling you he's not
a target he's merely a subject that
means he's a witness and everybody has
to testify as a witness it's not legal
pressure but it's public pressure the
special counsels office offered no
comment on whether Muller will prepare
an interim report addressing allegations
of obstruction and collusion though a
source told Fox the matter was discussed
but apparently not finalized with an
interview still under consideration
legal experts counseled president Trump
must be thoroughly prepared it has to
remember that the special counsels
office has been working on this for a
long time and probably knows a whole lot
about what happened and more than the
president probably remembers multiple
sources tell Fox News a special counsel
team has been following the financial
trail investigating whether money was
funneled into the campaign or after
election to gain influence over Trump
administration tonight that is reported
to include the questioning of Russian
oligarchs who traveled to the u.s. Chris
Catherine clanky welcome